persecución y exterminio son los cargos
por los que venezuela asegura que
llevará al presidente colombiano ante la
cpi venezuela
llevará a iván luque ante la corte penal
internacional
por el delito de término persecución
contemplado en el artículo 71 a que del
estatuto de roma la decisión se conoce
tras el asesinato de dos migrantes
venezolanos en el municipio colombiano
de tibú al este del país acusados de
haber robado un comercio el gobierno
venezolano denunció un supuesto
asesinato sistemático a sus migrantes la
vicepresidenta señaló que según el
instituto de medicina legal de colombia
se ha reportado el asesinato 2 mil 61
migrantes venezolanos desde 2007 el
gobierno de colombia rechaza y desmiente
las recientes declaraciones hechas por
distintos voceros de la dictadura de
nicolás maduro en donde denuncian una
supuesta política de acreción
discriminación o xenofobia hacia la
población
venezolanas
el gobierno de want to que defendió su
política de protección hacia los
migrantes venezolanos el presidente
anunció que regulará a un millón de
emigrantes antes de acabar el año a
través del estatuto de protección
temporal que asegura que los venezolanos
puedan acceder a derechos servicios y
oportunidades de integración por 10 años
colombia es uno de los principales
destinos de la diáspora venezolana se
estima que 1.8 millones de ellos viven
allí algo que ha despertado sentimientos
de xenofobia y señalamientos por ser
supuestamente responsables de un
empeoramiento de la seguridad según la
casa de nariño muchos de ellos habrían
llegado a colombia huyendo de la crisis
política económica y social que vive
venezuela